lagrange illinois a well-to-do commuter
town outside of chicago
terry and carol were high school
sweethearts here
two years ago they fulfilled a dream and
bought cafe 36 an upscale french bistro
there you are thank you very much and
for you sir my dream was to have my own
restaurant be my own boss okay thank you
i'm 58 years old is
at a time when most people are thinking
about retirement i'm just gonna get out
of the way for a while unless you okay 6
30
unless you want me to
do something i was very nervous with the
whole idea but let's try let's go
forward with the dream that he wants to
do okay talk to you later it gets me
upset that sometimes he doesn't delegate
i'll do the vacuuming i'll clean the
bathroom i'll get the bar stocked
leave this here for terry you go do what
you got to do we'll go smoke
terry why are you doing this work and
you have a staff standing back there why
are you doing it
okay and the onion soup and the onions
coming up that's coming up right now
pinot he's really a great chef the food
is tasty is good
and it's done right
[Music]
pinto's sanitation skills aren't the
greatest he uh he tastes a lot of his
food as he's making it
[Applause]
the running joke is you know do you want
a side of saliva with that i like
sticking my fingers in food
i think that cafe 36 would be a better
restaurant without pinto well nobody's
calling out tickets so i don't know you
know i mean it's just somebody's got to
be in charge this is the problem
terry and carol keep talking about how
pinto is so awesome and everybody else
knows pinto really can't run a kitchen
table 13 waited 25 minutes for a house
salad and a soup
the customer's reaction in the
restaurant is very positive mine is
not cooked they were raw i'm gonna send
mine back
really it's we're hurting at this time
we'll have nights that will only see
six or eight people for dinner service
we just don't understand
what's not working
i am so sick to my stomach i have chest
pains
carol and i have never taken a paycheck
since we started the business
here's the bills
more
more bills
i really love my husband want his dream
to come true that's all it's that drive
and that passion of the dream to say we
want to make it
[Music]
happen thank you
[Music]
cappy 36.
okay
comes ramsey
i just saw him walk by the window
hi hello mr ramsay good afternoon nice
to see you pleasure to have you with us
my name is terry gilmer i'm one of the
owners this is my wife carol ah how do
you do how are you very nice to meet you
my pleasure have you been here we're so
very happy to be here very excited what
kind of restaurant are you running we
try to style ourselves after what we
call an american bistro we're trying to
have fresh seafood steaks chops
sandwiches pasta yeah i can't wait to
taste okay right over there
oh the restaurant's big how many seeds
have you got uh we can see about 85 in
the main dining room right and henry's
book for lunch today
we have 11 people in the restaurant
right now and that's unfortunately a
little bit of a typical day for us this
is douglas douglas will be your server
today when chef ramsay walked through
our doors you know i was feeling really
good i thought you know this is going to
be great um special today the uh risotto
today is a wild mushroom that's pretty
good i'm dying to taste the risotto okay
yeah
this fascinates me i've never seen a
duck and a strawberry together yes well
yeah good chance to try it and i'll take
that rap
thank you so much crape of the day is a
sauteed atlantic salmon i serve an awful
lot of them but i'm not a big fan of any
crepes at all doug is this special okay
no okay so the crepes aren't special i
don't think so
okay
i know not to order the crepes because
they were frozen frozen crepes are crap
i got three courses pinto please fire
the crepe for a soda and the duck salad
please for chef ramsay to coming in is
it's very exciting am i nervous
no
i think everything is good always makes
me feel nervous when i sit next to
plastic grapes caked in dust
and the plates look like they've been
picked up at the local flea market
or the dollar shop
is this the normal um quiets or lunches
normally this lunches we average three
or four people three four yeah
unfortunately one of the problems is we
don't get the food out in time for to do
a business lunch holy mackerel let me go
check on your food
you ready
he wants a duck salad rare that doesn't
look very rare right no get it you know
what bring out the whole thing
guys holy [ __ ] i'm ready for the app no
one ever comes for lunch it's taking
this long
coming out where you two slog well we
fired it all
[Music]
does food always take this long yeah
i see your food put up how's it going
i'm relying on the chicago to suburb
train being pushed through the dining
room it's so old-fashioned
all right jeff wow
wow
the plane has a hat that's the wild
mushroom result
your duck salad rare starburst nice and
dirty they're just old plates or yeah
okay
rosetta
and i really got nervous when he started
eating but i believe that the food here
is
well
well above excellence
the risotto's
exploded mush
and it just disintegrates
in your mouth and it's very salty we'll
bypass that don't ask him to make
another one
way too salty little rice is mushy okay
just telling you what he's saying that's
fine the risotto came out nice it was
good it was really good i always know
that risotto was overcooked all the time
once gordon ramsay comes in here and
tells him this is mush this is
you know it's like yeah i've been saying
that for months but
orange strawberry duck right
[Music]
oh
jesus
what a bizarre combination what's with
the walnuts what are they doing candy
though the kidney wallets candied
walnuts
as if you need more sweet on there that
definitely didn't work
pink dog good crepes okay
when you see a chef putting those
ingredients together it's it's rather
sad ready clearly no one's controlling
him and
he hasn't got a [ __ ] clue
okay chef the next course your salmon
crates they come out like that normally
all the time
what they done chop them up um no that's
how he makes small time he just puts
extra on top i believe
who makes the crepes um i believe this
crepes are
store-bought yeah
damn look at that and this is the
speciality i'm fed up with eating crap
in the day what do you think of a crepe
you think of something nice light crispy
tasty not something mushy and hideous
that is shocking i thought you're
looking now i'm taking this away oh yes
please that's sucking up for you just
even gonna bypass the pigs
i don't think there was anything he even
said was okay i was
just in shock
and where did you train from i trained
uh in early and working in an italian
restaurant correct i thought the risotto
was an insult it was mush okay where is
the risotto rice it's in the cooler can
you get it yes
i'm just amazed that you lived in italy
that length of time you studied there
you worked there
and they didn't even teach you how to
make risotto
what's that date 2 20.
what's the date today
28.
you got the balls to walk in here on a
thursday and serve that [ __ ] from a week
ago
it's mush
there was no bed under still food and
nothing smell bad why in your tiny mind
you think it's still fresh from last
saturday it was in the
uh rich in cooler a reaching cooler
confirms in your mind that it's fresh
well i'm sorry but i mean you know this
is really weird for me this has been
going on for a while pinto tries to
stretch the food as far as it can go and
sometimes too far bring me everything in
that fridge as a week old you call
yourself the executive chef you should
be ashamed
you served me risotto from a week old
oh my god
all this is from last week
i was very shocked to find out that we
were not serving fresh products it was
such a horrible feeling and then i was
getting very angry and mad inside myself
to say how can my staff do this
chop clams we're keeping clamps from a
week ago smell that
what does it smell like that doesn't
it's not good smell
congratulations
you haven't managed to kill anybody off
what are you doing you're not a real
chef are you yes now
what any chef that keeps hold of that
crap in his fridge for a week two weeks
in my mind has given up a lack of caring
a lack of responsibility and more
importantly ignorance [ __ ] me what more
can you say
carol and terry have put everything they
have into cafe 36
unfortunately this restaurant may be too
far gone to save
that lunch time and that was a tough one
that one are you trained in the business
have you had a restaurant i have no no
have you ever had a ration before
absolutely not you've never had a rush
before no terry sorry how much did you
pay for the business a million two five
no million one million what i'm saying
we put our own savings ira accounts we
had a large four bedroom home that we
sold and used
the proceeds and the escrow from that to
put into the business and you're here
lunch and dinner yes
carol drops me off in the morning we
only have one car between us
we sold the other one
everything is very scary right now for
terry and i to see where we're headed
it's hard
it's hard when you
just put your faith in something you
really believe
and believe and believe and
it's still not coming i respect the
level of sacrifice here but you're
pondering and queering to why the
business isn't coming through the door
correct it's on the back of the food
when food's crap
it's crap
the chef's cooking me a risotto with
rice that's eight days old i i just i'm
still in shack yeah you have to focus on
the wrong not ignore it right yes
we certainly got an eye opener today
yeah i'm panicking
on both of yours behalf
i'm i'm so sorry i don't i'm not trying
to hurt your feelings you know that no
don't take it the wrong way please no i
understand and i'm here to make this
work you must understand that and that's
you know the objective from day one
um good to catch up thank you
[Music]
we got a mountain to climb and uh it's
uh it's a tough one
as the staff gets ready for dinner
service gordon ventures into the kitchen
to do a more comprehensive investigation
pesto vinaigrette looks like oil out of
my car engine unbelievable
everything's frozen
frozen and defrosted this place is a
mess
pinto
certified exec
what's going on here
what's all this stuff floating in water
that's the group are taken out of from
the freezer to keep it a fresh frozen
fresh frozen yeah sure there's no such
thing
see the pressure is frozen
what's this in water it's a salmon chef
frozen it was a fresh frozen
if you keep it frozen fresh frozen it
tastes more fresh
it's mad it is you're making all this
fresh stuff freezing it and then taking
it out two portions at a time per day
because it doesn't sell enough
what would you if you had planned your
business like this nothing to do with
business
that's lazy
everything's frozen
trout stuffing so we take it out we
still throw it
it's you know it's cold cold cold yes
slow thor we stuff the trout then we
re-freeze the trout
yes
i rest my case certified jerk
shefter the blooper was a strong smell
[Music]
it's dinner time and gordon is about to
see how this fine dining restaurant is
anything but fun hello good evening
welcome to cafe 36 welcome this evening
would you care to see our wine list i'll
start here with you
how are they they're terrific would you
be able to do the salmon material
sure i could do we needed for a cobia
and a salmon too
i'm very nervous very nervous and very
scared and
we're just hoping for the best
[Music]
escargot
this is the butter that we use for the
escargot it's parsley chive garlic the
butter's frozen as well
what don't you freeze
here's chef ramsay one of the best chefs
in the world telling pinto that you're
doing [ __ ] wrong in fact you're doing it
bad it was great to see pinto eat a
little humble pie what stuff don't you
freeze give me one ingredient like a
calamari comes in
the california pumpkin cookie we never
freeze it
so the only stuff you don't freeze
is the stuff that comes in frozen
astounded by what he's just witnessed in
the kitchen
gordon seeks out the owners terry and
carol i'm panicking pinto it's crap
i um i don't get what he's trying to do
there jeremy in terms of all this
fresh frozen stuff
everything in fresh cut up portioned
frozen
it's 45 minutes into dinner service and
most customers are still waiting for
their food
i feel like i'm drinking more than a
meat
you know that's probably the reason i
don't wear a watch because it takes
something long here the nightmare of
cafe 36 is still food time not being
able to get your food out of the kitchen
really makes your job as a server
difficult because that's pretty much the
description of your job to serve i think
they gotta catch the shrimp first
is this slow everything seems so slow
yes if you have one more person then it
goes faster yeah if you had one more
personal go faster yes sir eduardo no
wonder you've gone so old you've aged
waiting for the last main course
while the kitchen is struggling to cook
the food gordon also sees a problem with
the delivery
another departure holy crap i'm not
aware of any particular reason why we
serve and cards
i thought people got pushed into a
mortuary on trolleys no right not
serving food
would you like to hold the plate by the
hand or would you want to push a trolley
all day long i would rather hold them by
my hand
when the orders finally make it to the
tables customers find it's not worth the
wait
the new york's supposed to be medium huh
then new york's supposed to be medium
what is it medium rare right they said
chicken says medium
he said media when i was here why don't
you just put under the grill pintails if
we're in a position to argue
my things come back up doesn't mean i'm
a bad fool
and it's not just chef pinto's cooking
that catches gordon's eye
well these are people they're not even
seasoned asparagus are they no not right
now they're very expensive
they're very expensive so why have you
got them on a veggie off the dick
the veggie of the day yeah aren't you
bothered about the cost yeah it comes
from the different part of the worship
we can get it comes from the different
part of the world are you listening to
this yes sir
it's the most expensive vegetable on the
market you want that
and it's out of season
and you just put them on four dishes
this is unbelievable
tonight i'm starting to see new cooking
techniques that i've never ever seen
before slow though
fresh frozen but what's becoming really
clear is that he seriously is taking
this lovely couple for a ride and he's
got to stop
[Music]
this is true about pinto
he's telling you he's growing here
does that could that be
i hope not
[Music]
we don't know our ass
i'm so scared
[Applause]
[Music]
during dinner service owners carol and
terry were stunned by gordon's criticism
of their head chef pinto
we don't know our ass from a homeowner
i'm so scared
he opened our eyes to a lot of things
throughout the restaurant that
people have been taking advantage of us
so we have to
take a good hard look at everything
after a long difficult dinner service
the customers who have eaten are not
exactly thrilled chicken's a little
overdone
okay so too soupy and the chicken is
over done
i didn't even watch my salad because i
didn't really care for the dressing
and those who haven't been served are
not willing to wait we got here five for
seven okay okay so you know
five minutes
okay okay all right table five is gonna
walk out in five minutes but is this the
pace we move out is this as fast as we
go pinto has one speed and that speed is
[ __ ] you how long has it been
almost two and a half hours some of the
customers have given up completely on
cafe 36 and are leaving without even
eating an appetizer it's just been a
long day i have to really
take it all in it hurts
[Music]
after a rough night gordon confronts the
staff overall honestly
pretty disappointing
both in the kitchen and the dining room
there's one thing in here that i would
change
instantly
on the back of my experience today
and that's you
why
you are the executive chef you're
supposed to be a leader a motivator you
are seriously seriously leading this
place
into bankruptcy
because the big problem in this
restaurant pinto is in the kitchen
fresh frozen
slow four i think that pinto deserved
every single solitary second
of that ass riemann that he got from
gordon if this was your restaurant would
you be freezing everything porsching it
and then dropping in bowls of water
defrost it to re-cook it yes or no
[Music]
no i would have
embarrassing
[Music]
do you think i enjoyed standing there
and listening to this you know i'm a
proud man get the message
now show me your pride
chef
because i'm [ __ ] waiting
and unfortunately whether you like it or
not the two people behind you it's them
you're dragging down
that's why i'm pissed
to cut the [ __ ]
get ready for some changes because cafe
36 needs it urgently
good night
after witnessing a night of inefficient
and bizarre cooking techniques gordon's
first priority is to implement changes
in the kitchen if there's one thing this
restaurant needs right now is something
authentic
yes yes this restaurant needs a good
risotto
you you and me are going to cook risotto
together here is all our fresh
ingredients when i say fresh i mean
fresh i bought them myself this morning
are you ready let's go
cooking with the chef ramsay was it was
pressure it was a lot of pressure was on
this is just a really nice simple uh
porcini risotto mushroom zoo
that's sauteed already
finished with parmesan cheese and a
little knob of butter
make sure you're happy with it
mushroom risotto
[Music]
first change yeah risotto yeah second
change we'll be taking the plates out
tonight by hand faster and not running
up and down
with this [ __ ] thing all the way up
hey
we're gonna carry the plates
yeah by hand when chef ramsay took the
carts off the floor it was great i hated
them from day one so to me it was like
yes
i do have a usage for the trolleys
because tonight we'll come up with a
goat cheese salad special where you'll
be dressing the salad gives us more time
in the kitchen and we'll be doing like
goat's cheese fritters i absolutely love
the idea of having the salad made at the
table site sort of a little bit of
entertainment and showmanship yeah i
mixed greens in a touch of salt dr
pepper honey mustard vinaigrette yeah
i go cheese fritters yeah one
two
three
salad
so light vibrant exciting and more
importantly we're changing today we're
exchanging we're changing big time yeah
[Music]
as gordon starts to turn around cafe 36
he knows that what really needs to
change is terry
i'm gonna identify your uh weaknesses
and improve your strengths right and you
know pinto is a big weakness
don't ever be intimidated by controlling
chefs
and you've got to be strong you must be
strong
absolutely and i can see that now and i
think a lot of it was i'm more involved
in
you know the mundane daily operation the
things that i shouldn't be doing
and not watching the things that i
should and i can see that now what's at
stake is
my dream
and i'm not going to let anybody take it
away from me and you have got to start
being firm
because if you're not firm
they're never going to respect you
hi good evening welcome this evening for
we have you right over here lots of
people coming
all right let's rock and roll hi how are
you hello how are you tonight
good the feeling going into service
there you are getting all charged up and
ready to go let's all pull together and
let's get this roll
the chef has prepared a porcini mushroom
risotto today my special salad is a goat
cheese fritter salad cheese salad okay
two salads i'm gonna have that fillet
please collect this lake
okay take control now yeah will you
listen and say yes or no yeah yes yes
let's go
there you go phillip you have medium on
yes new york strip medium yeah
what's next please hey i got a crab
cakes a smoked salmon appetizer and
onion soup please right now i'm pretty
stressed out about tonight i don't want
anything to go like last night we're
trying to make this thing smooth the
operation tonight two risotto a trout
and a scallop okay good let's go two
results yes such presentation
first one i've ever done
thank you looks good
the goat cheese is excellent but while
the special salads are a huge hit
they haven't had their appetizer yet on
this table it's gonna be a few minutes
i want some basically half hours
cafe 36's characteristically slow
service continues to leave customers
waiting 45 minutes already while we go
with that one now yeah two summer will
shang 36v yes welcome chef working here
how long three minutes for me
i'm ready am i printer change gear you
always thought changing gear yep
unfortunately you're still in neutral
isn't it the risotto that's taking so
long
i'm sorry i don't know why i
swear it should be the next ticket up
i'm tired of working someplace where i
can't get the food out i can't service
my customers five has been waiting no
less than an hour and fifteen to an hour
it's gonna be like a
five minutes all right they told me that
like 30 minutes ago i swear to god i
just think pinto's making this crap up
as he goes along it's all a lie
unbelievable point y'all
you know red veggies for one for two
there's that that's what i said say it
over and over first time you said one
thing two one you said you got one there
and that's two veggies i'd say three
look at the problem look at the book hey
i got [ __ ] to do now i know
that's a speed up over there yeah
work as a team please last night you
worked as individuals tonight we're
gonna work as a team yeah yeah sure
let's go
i'm not having food hanging around
tonight no chance they just got theirs
they were seated before us so
explain that it's been a while though
chef pinto you lie to me and tell me
it's almost ready how long baby it's
gonna be a few minutes bro
i can't fire all these fans i just can't
do it
we're halfway through service and the
good news is we've sold 42 sellers which
is great sadly the bad news is that
barney and pinto they don't like each
other and that's affecting the service
things are slowing down and customers
are now starting to complain damn
we should have another new york medium
right
no
you guys aren't even working together
company you got to keep it driving don't
let it sink let's go i don't know where
we are i don't know
what you guys fire you have to call
anything out
huh i mean i don't know what's going on
pinto doesn't listen to me and
there's got to be a better system than
what we're doing because it's just not
working waited
this is cold
it isn't even hot
they're not even the center's back i'm
gonna go ahead and take these
this is the entree size portion correct
that's not an entree
that's appetizer pinto really can't cook
on the line
and pinto really can't run a kitchen on
the ticket it's got risotto dinner
unbelievable funny talk to your cook
yeah let's go make it a larger portion
it's too thick pour some more sack in
there okay i'll turn it down oh my god
now we're falling out now we're going
down boys just just two seconds dude you
as well yeah just come here for two
seconds yeah i'm not doing that in front
of the coaster come here none of you are
talking
you have got to talk together
he needs you yeah you need him
so we go back in there and we work at it
if he's sauteing you've got expedite
he's trying to expedite play and cook he
can't get in front of the tickets okay
now come on
i agree entirely with what chef ramsay
had to say about our performance this
evening
we weren't working together as a team
and
it hurt us it should be up in just
moments
dawn dude is lying to people right now
that's it
you know i'm
safe
with some of his customers still waiting
for their food and others giving up
altogether brian reaches his breaking
point now i gotta say two things that
are really hard
you're hiding
and you need to be fired
let me tell you something now you work
for me
i don't work for you you're awake
remember who you work
[Music]
i'm sorry i don't know why i
swear it should be the next ticket up
tonight the waiters of cafe 36 took a
lot of heat for the problems in the
kitchen
and brian is truly frustrated now i
gotta say two things that are really
hard
you're hiding
and you need to be fired
let me tell you something now you work
for me
i don't work for you
brian made some very harsh comments that
were extremely out of place
and it made me very upset to the point
that i almost fired him on the spot but
this has gone on way too far he's not if
you don't like working here
then keep your opinion to yourself i
want terry to start telling everybody
what to do
instead of letting the inmates run the
asylum you're a waiter remember who you
work for
after experiencing yet another
disappointing dinner service gordon is
curious to hear what the head chef has
to say okay um
pinto what do you think about tonight's
service
it was it was excellent it really was
everybody got involved
what kitchen were you in for me
uh barney truthfully is that the way you
saw service tonight
no i thought it was bad it was really
rough once again
complete different opinions
you're right though service was terrible
nothing was coming together no
communication no coordination
no teamwork customers waited tonight
they waited big time what did we do
what's going on how can this happen to
us
what did we do
let me just give you three major issues
that's wrong with this restaurant the
first issue is the service is way too
slow the second problem the food
is too inconsistent inconsistency is a
killer the third reason and one of the
most important reasons why this
restaurant is not busy it's not
contemporary a 1970s restaurant trying
to compete
in the 2008 market we're behind the
times we are behind the times okay
i'm going now i've i'm working all night
you know by time i see you tomorrow
morning we should have a well put
together plan
good night
that night gordon and his team went to
work doing away with the restaurant's
old-fashioned and outdated look creating
a more contemporary restaurant right
good morning how are you feeling no i'm
thrilled a big day today yes today's
relaunch day we're going to turn it
around yeah and put it back on the map
in we go
come through come through come through
oh my god how cool is this oh it's
modern it's awesome
wow
we've got a black and white color theme
yes and who knew i love black and white
so much it's been brought up into the
21st century beautiful it's a new
restaurant when i walked in the door i
just instantly felt alive
we've got rid of the old fuddy-duddy
stuff
[Music]
and now it's a really nice sharp
cutting-edge feel
i absolutely am getting choked up it's
just
what a dream
hey look at the plates
no more mismatched china
all the same it's wonderful it's amazing
now that we have matching plates it
looks like we know what we're doing back
here
the booths have been upholstered
i love the black
got new chandeliers
i'm just so
thankful that's unbelievable
a russian can't just survive on a new
decor yes it needs a new menu you have
to go with it
so we've gone
modern yes fresh approach and more
importantly we've condensed the menu i
think the kitchen should respond
favorably to the new menu unless they
screw it up with their usual [ __ ] it
should work out it's seasonal as well we
have everything in season i think that
the new menu is gonna make the kitchen
faster before dinner we'll make sure we
taste one of everything yes so you know
what you're selling
[Music]
tonight head chef pinto is cooking from
the newly designed menu and has one more
chance to prove himself to chef ramsay
first of all just look at the difference
appearance plates
portion size
start from the top onion soup grating
yeah perfect for the winter crab cakes
grilled chicken sandwich a grilled apple
cartoon mediterranean ragu filet mignon
tatar you like steak tattoos oh yes
and then one of my favorites the duck
comfy have a little taste get familiar
with the taste and textures
[Music]
i love that tartare
wonderful it's a whole new beginning and
chef ramsay did that for us let's take
advantage of tonight and let's show
lagrange yeah what we're made of
with the new menu and decor
carol and terry face one of the most
important nights ever at cafe 36. well
welcome to thecafe36 we're glad to have
you here at our grand reopening the
personality has changed it's more carol
and terry's when the oldest come in can
we call out the orders so we got some
form of vibrance in here a little bit
yes
yeah what do you think of the new menu i
think it's sure yeah it looks great yeah
it's night and day tonight we have to be
faster yeah and keep the standards up
yes great chance
[Music]
big big big night tonight and personally
i've never ever wanted a dinner service
to work as well as tonight because of
terry and carol because they so deserve
it and they're really endearing but i
honestly hope that pinto doesn't screw
this one up
please not tonight
[Music]
order on pinto all right we're coming up
with pinto
[Music]
as the orders make their way to the
dining room brian
your food's here the dinner service gets
off to a good start
you just got your entrance how was
everything so far really good good good
delicious fresh food simple menu i love
it all right am i ever gonna get a crab
cake with this right talk to me next
time we're coming please mario i got a
four four crab cakes but barely an hour
into service and the kitchen's bad
habits are back table number please 13
please 13. how long it takes like a six
minutes oh my god that's still not ready
i got every burner full man one empty so
i put something else on it okay pinto we
have to go a little bit now yeah
when you're looking at all these tickets
sometimes things can be a little slow
pinto if we go quiet nothing's happening
we need some form of voice in here pinto
was renting the tickets while pinto got
behind
but he's the chef and he should be in
control of the situation
all right come on guys you got to talk
to each other yes yes
we just gotta talk to each other guys
pinto
[Music]
pinto
pinto
[Music]
executive chef
certified dick
once again pinto's inefficiency in the
kitchen is upsetting both customers
and staff i'm just pissed off i just
can't take this man i hope terry strains
us out
the real problem right now is they can't
seem to finish any food back there it's
just like really bad sex it keeps going
on and on and at some point you just
wish it would be over cancel my entree
cancel your entry right i'm leaving it's
been more than fair it's been six thirty
it's been three and a half bucks that's
what i'm saying yeah it's a little
little hectic tonight
i gotta go i'm just standing doing
nothing i know i i agree nobody's
communicating no one's even stepping up
to the mark and watch what barney's
doing barney's now trying to read the
tickets cook saute and expedite yeah
and pinto is just trying to dress the
salad not good enough that's not a team
effort yeah i could see it nothing's
been directed
unbelievable gordon ramsay really did
give me a swift kick in the butt to say
you know
wake up if you're going to have your
business be a success
you have to take charge
what are we waiting on where are we at i
need those two crab cakes right now
coming up all right come on guys hey i
need to get this food out i got tables i
got to turn we can't fall behind
thank you eddie go all right
talk to me what's next with terry
finally staying on top of his chef two
steak tartare
apple salad crab cake the kitchen gets
back on track
cheers we got our food thank you
salmon there's two salmon in the oven
okay beautiful keep it coming guys i got
to get this dining room turned over we
got a lot of people waiting i think
terry's eyes have been opened up two
risottos who is also playing right there
you know you should give everybody the
benefit of doubt but you should also
demand performance out of them that's
all i want it's just communication for
the first time since gordon's arrival
the back of the house let's see if we
can finish these last two tables strong
shall we yeah
let's go he's in sync with the front
i'm following him
here here to terry lively
and it was terry who made it happen
you have a beautiful restaurant thank
you it is it's it's so much more
beautiful
amazing amazing potential
very rare you come across a couple
today in this industry
and the back of the commitment it takes
the sacrifice the personal life you're
so unselfish it's untrue
and
you're so
perfect for each other it's
extraordinary and that's quite rare
and i really mean that
i can't tell you what to do with pinto
but you know my feelings
but
when
you make a decision
i hope
to hell that you don't make it too late
you talked about change
you know and that we have to do that and
i can't you know
hold back any longer no more all these
on the radio no more
the biggest thing i've learned is i have
to definitely be more aggressive and
running my business
i have to take full charge and
i have to change and i've already
changed you've done so much for us
it's just an incredible feeling that
you've done that for us
you know you said we had to get rid of
the whole
and back from the 30s yes about 30 years
ago yeah so we got
are you guys uh yes so this is from
our own personal wine collection oh my
god and i can't take that come on that's
the bottle of shadowy chem 1976. you
said i would thirty years ago so we're
past it never oh god
can i keep it here for when i come back
absolutely
and
when i come back we can have a glass
together
we would love that would you
absolutely
like you too honestly i'll see you later
the most perfect mum and dad
unbelievable right
thank you so much
oh dear good luck sir thank you yes you
thank you and you deserve everything you
know that you stand strong and you
listen to this lady yes yes she's a love
on my life good to see you
thank you
so much there's absolutely
a light at the end of the tunnel
and in fact it's bigger than just a
light i think there's a whole sunshine
coming out best wishes thank you yes
okay
we got work to do right yeah we do oh
they do
[Music]
that's tough really tough what can you
say about a couple that sacrificed so
much to get where they have today and
what can you say about a couple that are
so devoted to each other
incredible i know what you can say
damn i hope they succeed because they
deserve to
so much
there is one last footnote to this story
relaunch night was the last night pinto
worked at cafe 36 he left the very next
day
and barney was promoted to head chef